during a Senate hearing on Wednesday. Republican
Senator Mike Lee, I guess, recovered from
Corona virus, said fact checking is a form
of censorship. This is one of the guys who
loves wearing no mask. He caught Corona virus.
He went to a Senate hearing. Didn't wear a
mask despite having been diagnosed with the
virus just days earlier. Complete total clown
show on Wednesday.
There was a hearing held with the CEOs of
Twitter, Facebook and Google. The topic was
Section 230. As you know, Donald Trump has
been talking about repeal section 230. It
relates to a legal responsibility to social
media companies for the content that's published.
But what it led to was a lot of Republicans
going mask off, not just Laeter, not just
literally, but also mask off figuratively.
Here's Mike Lee saying fact checking is a
form of censorship.
And when I use the word censor here, I meaning
I mean, block content, fact check or label
content or monetize Web sites, fact checking,
labeling something not trustworthy, saying
something is untrue.
It is all censorship to Mike Lee. So let me
sort of interpret this for you in realistic
terms. When your entire world view is based
on falsehoods and your entire political movement
is based on lying to people in order to get
them to vote for you. Yeah, fact checking
is a problem for you, but it's not censorship.
If I say, for example, Mike Lee perpetrated
the non-existent Bowling Green massacre. Remember
when Kellyanne Conway made up the Bowling
Green Massacre? If I say Mike Lee perpetrated
that. If I get fact checked. Is that censorship?
Of course not. And Ted Cruz at the hearing
stated sort of. He started going in the same
direction, really, really dangerous now because
you are seeing more and more of the Republican
Party push this idea. Republicans don't actually
believe in freedom of speech, even though
they claim to be the stalwart defenders of
the Constitution. They just want to be free
to lie to you without anything, making it
tougher for them to convince you of those
lies. And in this case, the Republican Party
wants to understand what they're saying legally
force private businesses whose rights normally
they defend. They want to force private businesses
like Facebook and Twitter to allow them to
lie to you with no consequences. I thought
they were about deregulating business. I thought
they were about getting government out of
the business of private industry. So to them,
every time someone interrupts their lies with
reality, we are infringing on their right
to be ignorant of reality. This is the delusional,
backwards perspective that they bring to the
table on this issue.
Now, as far as Section two 30 is concerned,
I don't know if this is a bigger topic, but
if you repeal Section two 30, you would probably
see at least some of these social media companies
be stricter police officers, so to speak,
of what is published to their platforms because
they would be more cautious about possibly
having consequences themselves, about untrue
or defamatory information being posted by
individuals on their platform. So this is
a bigger topic. And, you know, after the election,
when things hopefully calm down, we'll have
actual maybe intellectual property attorneys
on to talk about it. But there's actually
a chance that repealing Section 230, which
Trump has been talking about, may not be so
good for the Republican lies that they are
looking to spread an unfettered for lack of
a better term. But that's a bigger conversation,
which we will we will certainly have. Let
me know your thoughts. I'm on Twitter at David
Pakman later today. I will be addressing a
few. There've been some questions that a lot
of people have been asking me. One is, David,
you criticized Trump a lot uncovered.
But what would Biden what should Biden have
done differently? I will address that. I've
been getting messages from people saying,
David. Election Day is it? Why should ballots
be counted after Election Day? Well, if they've
been sent by Election Day, they should be
counted. And I will get into that a little
bit later today.
And I will also take some of your calls of
a discord at David Pakman dot com slash discord.
That's d i. S c o r d.
Great program. The last Friday show before
the election,